joker shack here first thing thank you
because of you the big man is back
you're the first big man to win an mvp
in a long time
i thank you and i appreciate you very
much coming from serbia as a kid did you
ever say to yourself
i will be a mvp in uh nba one day no
to be honest like i didn't even think
i'm out of
being nba you know uh my goal
in that when i started to play a
basketball back home
it was playing at euroleagues because
that was kind of the closest the lead
the closest top league
[Music]
[Applause]
to my country you know i can play in
some big
big big clubs in serbia and kind of
grind my
way up but um when when daniel nuggets
uh the demolition
drafted me it was um it was a
opportunity uh for me to to become an
nba player
and i think i did a good job of using
that opportunity
you know nicola number one
congratulations
who was the first coach who made you
believe in yourself
we used to like he said no you're gonna
be a great player because there's always
a coach who gives you that things like
give you that supreme confidence what
coach would you like to thank
for giving you that supreme confidence
uh
but to be honest in every every course
that i have
really gave me a freedom to do kind of
my thing you know
so every coach gave me an opportunity to
show my skill
set or whatever so but the
the kind of the coach who who really
tell mep as a word in my name in
synchronization
is it's felipe our strength coach so he
was the he was the only one
like two one and a half year ago two
years ago he was telling me mvp and
pmp and he was kind of the first guy who
pulled that in my in my brain i can say
like that
you know congratulations and uh on being
the mvp of the nba sounds product
overwhelming but there had to be a point
like you said you didn't think about
that
but what point in this season you what
you looked around and said
man this could be it it was there a
particular point
that happened but the difference between
this year i think i started a season
real well i mean we ended we ended uh
about a season in bubble and we had a
really good season last year
and we had like month and a half two
months uh rest i can say
and i i started the season really well
and i played i played kind of the whole
season really well um
stat wise you know and
i was i think this was my best season of
my life
and uh the kind of the the the
chair on the top is probably the trophy
that i i got so
i i think that this is my the best
season of my life